the tornado ripped through here in the
dead of night the small town of Rolling
Fork Mississippi reduced to Rubble in a
matter of minutes
people who live here were killed in
their own homes those who survived
finding makeshift ways to Shield
themselves from the onslaught
all this glass shot down the hallway and
peppered everybody and they held up a
door that hadn't been hung yet they held
up a door in the hallway to try to block
some of that and my mom threw a blanket
over my grandmother and held it and just
held it down
from above the path and the scale of the
destruction is clear here residents
received a text alert urging them to
take cover just seven minutes later it
was upon them wind snapping trees like
toothpicks churning up houses and cars
the state broke many feeling they were
lucky to be alive we lost everything but
we got our life told the house out told
my truck out
the car and the other car but we good
powerful storms do happen in the Deep
South particularly at this time of year
on Friday night Texas Mississippi and
Alabama were in its path
the rural and poverty-stricken towns of
Silver City and Rolling Fork Mississippi
hit first before it moved towards
Alabama with Winds of up to 70 miles per
hour in Texas two tornadoes with 100
mile per hour winds struck leaving five
people injured
satellite images captured the magnitude
of the storm from above
but on the ground the focus remains on
rescuing anyone trapped alive in this
wreckage it is difficult work with many
of these towns still without power in
some parts of Mississippi Water Supplies
are contaminated too
Volunteers in these close communities
have been quick to offer help
but authorities are warning that the
number of dead will likely rise Martha
callner Sky News